there has not been in the history of
humanity across any culture any book any
story any Fable there has never been
across the history of humanity any
respect but on the name of a promiscuous
female ever ever you name the biggest
conquerors that you can possibly name
from history Genghis Khan Alexander the
Great all of them they all had 100 wives
bunch of children Big G conquered the
world normal that is normal evolutionary
biology that's how men are designed to
be there's never been a single female
who's been celebrated for a promiscu
ever in history it's always been frowned
upon and disgusting so yes we are
completely and utterly different yes
it's different if a woman cheats on a
man and if a man is at a complete top
level of his life and ticks every single
box and if he decides to be loyal which
some do and I can be loyal and I have
been loyal but there's also times in my
life where I think [ __ ] it I don't want
to be and get a new girlfriend every
single day of the week I can do that and
I can decide to do that if a woman
decides to do the same purely because
her value is high enough to attract so
many males because she's beautiful for
example it is completely different and
I'm gonna explain to you why it's
completely different so buckle up it's
different it's different it's different
well I told and why it is impossible for
a female to be promiscuous on a long
enough period of time without devaluing
herself because she is [ __ ] people
she shouldn't be [ __ ] there is no way
she is sleeping with endless men and all
of them are either high value men or
treating her the way she should be
treated if you find a woman who slept
with 50 100 dudes she's either [ __ ]
dudes which are at her level or haven't
worked hard enough to try and get the
[ __ ] she was just too drunk to realize
he's a loser who plays video games or
she's [ __ ] a top geek who barely
texts her back so either way she's
[ __ ] dude she shouldn't be [ __ ] or
a guy who's at the level who doesn't
give her the right amount of attention
for a woman to find a guy who's truly on
a level who truly treats her the way she
should be treated that's once every
couple years if that you ain't just
gonna go out there [ __ ] a new dude
every week and say yeah he's worth [ __ ]
yeah he treats me good enough to get my
[ __ ] and you know what's funny about
the universe it's actually beautiful
about the universe because it's equal
and opposite forces when you devalue
yourself it's kind of like men can smell
it on you they can just look at a [ __ ]
and go oh and that's the way it works so
you have to be very careful to female
and sit and go does this man truly
deserve to [ __ ] me if you think about it
the answer 99 of the time especially if
you're promiscuous is no so when a woman
is sleeping around with all these men
she's devaluating herself she's
devaluing herself and the world knows
God knows the universe knows when a man
does it he doesn't devalue himself at
all that's just the way it works can I
ask you a question wait wait wait wait
answer one second son may I ask you a
question what would you say if a woman
now is married to two men
no I'll tell you why let's talk about
this what is the difference between a
man let's say me I have four wives right
what's the difference between a man
having four wives and a woman having
four men you can impregnate the four
wives at the same time you're getting
pregnant the four wives at the same time
and we know who the parents are right
see let's say you had four pregnancies
you'd know who the mother is because
she's carrying the baby and you know who
the dad is top G if you had a woman with
four men and she gets pregnant who's
supposed to parents what about if but no
but I'm asking okay I ask what if
they're different races
you don't know the question now modern
science can come along and maybe fix
that for you but that doesn't mean it's
not wrong in the eyes of God the idea of
having a family the idea of a child
being born one of the baselines for a
new life to come onto this planet is for
at least to understand who the two
people who made it are at least if you
have a woman [ __ ] four Dudes you
don't even know who's who who are
pregnant
wait wait have you seen the twins that
had two different dads Oh that's oh yeah
I saw that may I just say something then
so if that is the case yeah if the one
thing that your mentor Hobbies you at
least you know who the two people that
put that child on Earth are then that's
why promiscuity for men is also a
problem because they get women pregnant
sometimes they don't even know they have
children that's around no no it's
completely different it's different
because you have to understand I'm
talking about humans you look at humans
from a societal perspective but Society
has changed right so let's say two three
hundred years ago if a woman got
pregnant she needed a man to survive if
that man didn't take care of her during
pregnancy she was going to die she
couldn't work a job she couldn't hunt
couldn't fish whatever right a woman
literally needed that man for survival
so if if you were to come to me and say
I'm pregnant but you've been [ __ ] by
four different dudes I'm like who says
it's mine why am I looking after you
none of I want to look after her she
will literally perish this is why in
most of the world today still today
virginity is so coveted and throughout
all of history it's been so coveted
because that's the only way to ensure
paternity she's a virgin I know that's
my baby she a virgin proves it's mine
outside of this modern science [ __ ]
shaitan the devil we have here in the
West in most of the world today we
without virginity or at least a low body
count or at least uh anti-promiscuity
you can't tell that that's your baby so
it's a completely different thing you're
looking at the idea of a man a woman
being pregnant and coming to a group of
men and saying one of you has to take
care of me and put up with me when I'm
fat and Moody and annoying and I need my
bills paid and all the men are gonna sit
there and go no [ __ ] no prove it's mine
you can't prove it bounce where it's
different if I get four women pregnant
we know that we know the deal okay so
let me ask you a question so obviously
back then for Survivor women needed a
man otherwise when they were pregnant
could die and all of these things they
would perish in today's society given
Evolution given the fact that as women
we can go again yeah but I'm I'm not
saying that isn't there a glitch between
what is actually happening and the
nature of what we have in our bodies I
think that's probably the conflict that
we're having right now glitch in what
way in the sense that women don't feel
like they need men in the most physical
sense perhaps like naturally it's very
interesting women don't feel like they
need men in a physical sense because
life is soft but it's but it's but it's
[ __ ] and it's [ __ ] because you
still need Men by proxy one and two the
second life gets difficult you very
quickly you very quickly learn how much
you need men but women don't go I'm
independent I don't need no man because
I have an only fans and men being my
only fans and if anyone comes up to me
I'll call a male police officer I don't
need men shut up [ __ ] idiot of course
you do you just named your whole life
it's based on [ __ ] men the roads are
driving along was paved by a man the
house you're living in was built by a
man the car you're driving who was
designed by a man your whole life
depends on men and the second anything
bad were to happen to you the second you
were physically threatened or times were
to get hard or War were to start or
famine or riots the first thing you do
is find a big strong man [ __ ] yourself
until the feminism out the window
feminism goes out the [ __ ] window the
second that the snow needs shoveling or
there's a [ __ ] broken down car or the
tire needs changing then all that crap
vanishes it's garbage and this is the
actual very interesting thing I'll make
a point here which is gonna be canceled
again but I don't give a [ __ ] but this
is the point feminism in and of itself
can't be defended any idea the point of
an idea is that it could be defended by
the people who believe in it this is
what the whole point of War since the
dawn of time it doesn't matter if it's
the Christians against the Hindus
doesn't matter if it was the Germans
against the French there were people who
had ideas and ideology these and they're
prepared to fight each other to defend
their ideology feminism is an ideology
which cannot be defended by feminists
the only people who could defend
feminism are The Men Who subscribe to
the garbage with you if you're all the
feminists were to get in a line and say
we want feminism and the conservative
men were to get in a line you would
learn very quickly it's [ __ ] I had a
friend in Afghanistan when Taliban
kicked America out and he told me
the Americans were telling were telling
the girls that could go to school so
they built all these girls schools and
they put the afghanistani Defense Forces
there and they'd get funded the
Afghanistan forces to to protect these
schools you had American satellites you
had night vision goggles Taliban were
afraid to attack America leaves now you
have Afghani Defense Forces they're
basically blind they don't have
satellites anymore don't have a night
vision whatever so now it's a real war
the men are standing next to this girl's
school the Taliban are coming there's
some dude you're standing there and
you're looking at this girl's school
going
I don't really give a [ __ ] if girls go
to school bounce and you just and you
didn't fight so that's why they all gave
up and Taliban took over so quickly and
when I said this to girls like yeah they
should have fought for us feminism to
why don't the women fight can I ask the
women can't defend their own [ __ ]
idea you need men to defend feminism so
that's why the whole thing is stupid so
the second men don't defend it it does
it just fails it's a [ __ ] ideology
it's garbage may I tell you something
now so this is the thing this is when we
assume that women perhaps don't have the
physical or even mental ability to go to
school wait wait because this is the
thing for example in Ukraine a lot of
women took up arms and in fact I'm
angolan wait wait I'm angolan wait wait
I'm angolan listen people at home wait
no worries I'll talk about my person
wait let me tell you let me tell you
something this is the thing I think it's
also really like silly to assume that
for example woman because she didn't go
to school she'll not be as intelligent
as a man therefore naturally a woman is
not intelligent no it doesn't make sense
if we're now starting to normalize
equality and we want to put everybody in
the Forefront give a woman a normalized
inequality well that's what what people
are wanting then
I carry myself differently I actually
hold the things I have done in the fight
side for I hold it that's why when you
speak to me I don't move different I
move different to many of the girls
that's why when you talk to me and you
argue with me I don't take it you do
something and I'll tell you something a
lot of women may have the accolades to
be somebody but they're uncomfortable to
own that and the reason why then I would
like to ask you for example
um I do need a man for example to you
know procreate but other than that I'm
quite strong and I would find things
that I would find a way to protect
myself differently with that mentality
what would be the man that would be for
me then another what would you do if one
of these security guards broke into your
door what would I do okay I'll tell you
what do you do
okay they see you're not dead it's okay
no I'll be like this and then if not
maybe I would kind of like be very
gentle and comply to find a way to get
out okay so if they want to come and
kill me there's not much that many
people because it's like an important
Point you're talking about a quality
equaling respect the way you get respect
as a woman is by being feminine there's
nothing we can be equal and very very
different I'm not saying that when
there's not equality but you've confused
equality with the same you can be equal
with completely different things you can
have a bishop and a knight on a
chessboard they're equal in terms of
points but they do different things
right a woman can have equal respect to
a man if she is very good at being a
woman and a man gets respect for being
very good at being a man when a woman
decides she wants to act like a man or a
man wants to act like a woman that's
where all gets [ __ ] up we're trying to
pretend it's all saying it's not the
same men and women are good at different
things we have different strengths
different weaknesses there's nothing
wrong with accepting that there's
nothing wrong with saying I'm a woman
I'm good at X he's a man is good at why
then we work together as a team we have
a beautiful family we're happy forever
it's only confused where you have women
who sit and go no because in the name of
equality we can fight and work there's
no [ __ ] women on the front line in
Ukraine that is silent [ __ ] they put
some chick there dancing around these
Pokemon dancers to try and convince men
it's garbage if you go to the front line
of Ukraine right now you do not see
women in their makeup and their
manicures you see [ __ ] men in the
freezing cold dying you know where the
women are Dubai chilling that's where
the women are so to sit and pretend that
women are just as capable physically as
men as a [ __ ] lies delusion
descending your strongest man is
delusion you are good at all the things
you're better than men at a lot of
things but it's not the physical world
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible